welcome to another dr. Sadler chalk and
talk this lecture series in which I
address questions problems issues
concerns that could either sent to me by
readers viewers emailed to me by people
or which come up in classes and
conversations and I think could be kind
of useful for people to think about to
reflect upon this is something that has
been I've been thinking about for a very
long time
in part because every time that I teach
Plato's Republic before or shoot a video
about it there's always somebody who
says AHA that looks exactly that
tripartite division that looks exactly
like what's going on in Freud can I map
the two of them onto each other and the
simple answer is no not really
but I want to talk about why that's the
case is there really a connection
between Plato's tripartite version of
the human soul and Freud's
tripartite model of the human psyche in
order to figure that out we have to
actually lay them out for us so let's
let's look at what what we actually have
Plato says that we have the human being
and at least with the soul part there's
also the body but the body is closely
connected with the appetites we have
three parts when he hears this modeled
after a ideal City and I'm not going to
go into that because there's there's
plenty of videos out there about that he
says we have a rational part of our soul
the part of our soul with which we we
learn with which we reason which we
think and this part of our soul is very
important when it's functioning well it
can direct us towards our goods what it
is that that human beings need desire
will be made happy by we also have an
amputated part of the soul we have
desires that draw us after different
things food drink sex laying around and
sleeping all day you know there we have
the bodily appetites usually tied to
things that have to
with the body then we have this third
part of our soul which is concerned with
on the one hand matters of honor and
dishonor so it's looking at how other
people see us and how we thereby see
ourselves whether we have value or or
don't whether we're being treated lower
than we deserve or being treated higher
than we deserve it's a part with which
we also feel shame play to all things
but it's also the part with which we get
angry it's the part of us that has
dynamism to it the appetite you know
pull us in different directions but
they're they're fairly simplistic this
part of our soul is like think about a
constantly churning it calls this the
most which is in some Greek authors the
very word for anger and this is logos
and this is epithelia desire so we have
these three parts and in order for a
human being to be doing well they all
have to be functioning the way that
they're they're supposed to that's
Plato's view we'll come back to it and
let's look at Freud's now Freud let's
start from the bottom that makes most
sense before Freud we have something
that's like the appetite part called the
in its this repository of desires that
are not you know well thought out that
are for the most part unconscious or
subconscious we find ourselves driven by
them this is the part of us that wants
to just sleep eat have sex you know
enjoy ourselves all the time that
demands those sorts of things so that is
kind of similar to play this thing and
then we have the super-ego now I'm
jumping to the top and the super-ego is
the part of the soul in which morality
in a kind of stilted formulaic you know
pushing down on you giving you rules
kind of sense sense of duty all that
sort of stuff that's where that resides
and with Freud thinks that that actually
is is just the internalized voices
commandment
ideas of other people who you've been
involved with you've made them part of
your own psyche so you get to this kind
of babble or perhaps you know fairly
unified chorus of voices saying thou
shalt thou shalt not inside of your head
and the poor ego that's where you are
for the most part that's the conscious
part of yourself with which you actually
make decisions think about who you are
and the ego is torn in part between the
demands of the super-ego to do the right
thing which super-ego actually it's
define the right thing
and the it for whom the right thing is
always whatever is going to give me the
most enjoyment right now so the ego is
is the part that mediates between the
two of them and it's really where the
human being most is for Plato the human
being really is most here in these parts
so let's talk about the functions now
these parts what are they supposed to do
so in Plato's model and in Freud's model
the it in the apathetic part really look
pretty similar they're doing more or
less the same kind of stuff they're
telling us hey you see that attractive
person over there go try to have sex
with them if you can't have sex with
them at least you know like look at them
and then talk with them hey that beer
over there
drink it up hey what's that going down
over there let's go take a look that's
what the the end and the apathetic
partner are doing for Plato the appetite
of part is also particularly interested
in making money - yeah greed would be an
issue you know a failure of the appetite
of part I don't think well you could say
that that that fits in with Freud once
money becomes a symbol for the things at
the end truly desires so there it works
now what about the rational part
rational part it's supposed to be
thinking out what is actually good
for the person it's supposed to be
giving orders that the spirited part
that helps to impose on the appetite of
part it also does give orders to the
spirited part and it's able Plato
doesn't spell this out that much but
it's able to give orders to itself you
know if it realizes that it's thinking
is is out of whack it can say I got to
fix this let me let me figure out how I
can think better maybe I take a critical
thinking class you know or hey spirited
part you need to be an anger management
apathetic part no you can't eat thirds
with every single meal and wash it down
with a six pack each time so the
rational part gives rules it does this
hopefully in light of genuine knowledge
about what is good or bad for human
beings and what is good or bad for me as
a human being the spirited part it has a
function as well actually several
functions one is it supposed to protect
us we do need to get angry about some
things we also do need to be concerned
about how other people view us so that
we can you know whether they're trying
to push us down we can push back we can
rightly evaluate those those sorts of
things we do need to have you know a
desire for that that is not simply a
matter of model the appetite of desire
something that's a little bit more
transcendent to them the spirited part
doesn't do a lot of you know going
around and learning things for its own
sake it's primarily oriented towards
what you know what is making us angry or
calm or what has to do with honor our
viewpoints on ourselves local all sorts
of things that the spirited part is
supposed to be an ally to the rational
part in imposing its rule upon the
appetite apart so that's Plato what
about Freud well yeah we've already
talked about that what does the
super-ego do that's a good question
the super-ego does give commands that
sort of push down so it's kind of like
the rational part and if the super-ego
is is working particularly well I
suppose it will and get the ego to sort
of go along with its demands and push
down the it or at least you know
repressed
it's impulses which is going to make the
ego actually quite unhappy there's
there's a big difference whereas the
spirited part when it's really
functioning the way it's supposed to for
Plato and when the rational part is
giving you no proper directions of the
spirited part the spirited part is doing
exactly what it was made for it feels
great whereas the ego when it's dealing
with the the commands of the super-ego
being imposed on the the end it's really
torn it's really not in not in a happy
condition that's why he goes psychology
was in part to you know set up you know
the ego as opposed to the secret
super-ego and the yet a later
development of Freudian psychology that
you know obler and people like that what
else does a super-ego do is it really
rational
that's a good question does the
super-ego really know what is good or
even inquire into what is the good for
human beings know the super-ego is in a
certain respect more imitative it
reflects and mimics what it is that has
been internalized so if you had a lot of
people who thought that you know for
example you should never back down to a
fight don't you ever do that don't be
like those putz is over there and those
cowards over there be like you know all
the rest of us tough guys that could be
your super-ego and then that's pushing
down on your ego that may not be the
best thing for you or we must never ever
discuss sex at the dinner table
because that's not what nice people do a
lot of people have a super-ego as well
all right there's nothing that
guarantees that what's going on in the
super-ego is gonna be rational in the
super-ego is not capable of reflecting
upon itself to determine whether it is
really in line with rationality there
it's very different than Plato's
rational part isn't it the ego doesn't
necessarily have to be the actual you
know tough guy corresponding to the
military of the police that what the
spirited part in Plato's vision does
correspond to
now of course you could have a slack
spirited part that's unable to you know
impose itself but this is the part of
the human being that's actually able to
get angry at yourself and say get the
appetites in check you know can the ego
do that it's debatable the other thing
to keep in mind too is so if the
super-ego is not really rational where
do you rationale 'ti come in here in the
Freudian model comes in in the ego
doesn't it if at all that's the place
where a reflection is able to occur at
least with traditional you know Freudian
Theory it gets complicated when we look
at other sort of variants but that's the
part that's able to you know sort of
make decisions so in a way you know the
ego is a little bit like the spirited
part of the superhero is a little bit
like the rational part but they're
actually quite different from each other
in many respects based on their their
functions you could also think about
this in terms of the relations between
the parts you know do the relations they
actually pan out the same and I think
the answer is largely no except in that
this bottom part remains more or less
similar you know and you simply cannot
lock all the appetite a part of the into
run wild because if if unchecked they
they will run what constitutes a
disorder for a person what's a
disordered soul Plato says that when a
person commits injustice it's because it
comes out of the injustice within their
soul to disharmony between these these
three parts there's something wrong
either with the individual parts or the
way in which they function in relation
to each other so think about a person
for example who is dominated by the
appetite apart who who is dominated by a
need to make more and more money and
evaluate everything in terms of money
for whom even their self-worth is tied
up with money and their rationalities is
exclusively put to the service of making
lots and lots of money
they're unable because of the deficiency
in the rational part to reflect on this
and say wow I've really screwed things
up I've gone off the tracks they're
unable to put limits on their appetites
and they actually the appetites are
running the show at that point they're
on top Plato also thinks that the
spirited part could assert its dominance
over the rational part and it can be
quite ascetic you know keeping the
appetites in check but solely concerned
with with honor something that my
students often point out to me as there
could be problems even with the rational
part being sort of detached from these
other things and not taking their proper
needs desires into account and being far
too intellectual and ascetic and these
could all be disorders from a Platonic
point of view what about Freud well you
know for Freud one of the biggest
problems like I put it out is you have
the end saying to the ego hey I want I
want I want so it's putting pressure on
the ego that way and the super-ego
likewise putting pressure there and the
ego for ego is trapped in between is the
locus of conflict and within you know
sort of traditional Freudian theory
where you're using these these three
these three functions these three parts
of the soul these three parts of the
psyche because
Freud didn't always use this he had
other models as well but if you're using
this the in ego is the locus where the
conflict is sort of spilling out but the
conflict is actually taking place behind
the scenes and what's going on here
what's going on here one may not even be
very conscious of what what is in one
super-ego
certainly the it is in large respect
unconscious and a lot of the disorders
play out in the field of the ego and the
ink of the egos like God I don't I have
no idea what's going on with me why do I
you know find myself just you know
I'm Jar Jar after peanut butter and then
just putting them on the shelf
I don't know there's something wrong
with me or you don't pick whatever sort
of other weird example you know that
you've got and there's lots of disorders
that come out of this and the disorders
come about in large part not because you
know the three parts are in disharmony
with each other then there's some sort
of proper harmony the Freudian view is
that there's always going to be some
degree of disharmony and probably what
you have to do is either you know
strengthen the ego like ego psychologist
did or figure out what's wrong with the
inn or what's wrong with the super-ego
maybe quit listening to the super-ego if
you can you know maybe the super-ego is
actually you're you know fundamentally
irrational or you know you can you can
focus on the subject rather than the ego
the way somebody like Lacan did I don't
want to go too deep into that sort of
stuff what I want to close with is in
thinking about what the the purposes of
having these models are psychotherapy is
therapeutic platonic philosophy is not
meant to be merely descriptive nor
merely prescriptive in the sense of
life's telling you here's what exactly
what you need to do here's the kind of
person you need to be it's also meant to
be therapeutic as well
Socrates saw himself as trying to help
people in that sort of Plato so there's
there's goals here of trying to live a
more human more integrated more happy
life they have different views of what
they would would constitute one of the
things that Freud said that was
particularly striking and a lot of
analysts and commentators and brought
this up as this German phrase Louis bar
Zoli garden now s is the end it is just
laughing for
s is the German before that that means
that right neuter it is ego ego is the
Latin for I it is the German for I so
we're this unconscious seething driving
us getting us into all sorts of trouble
going off into weird corridors of of
action habit thoughts you know desire
where that was we want this to be we
want to become conscious of what the
hell is going on with me and with other
people now notice that doesn't say
anything about the super-ego does it
where is now Plato's view would be
something more like the rent like you
said the rational part should be running
the show telling the spirited part get
those the appetites to do what I'm
telling them to do and then telling the
appetites hey you you can't eat as much
as you want here's the right amount for
you to eat
let's just stay within these these
bounds and we're gonna be a-okay so
these are very different projects I
think they do both if you use them right
they do both involve self-discovery and
being able to make decisions about what
kind of person one wants to be they
propose to us quite different models the
Freudian one in some respects is more
open-ended and it's also in certain
respects more pessimistic about the
capacities of reason to really do much
with this sort of thing Plato's view is
actually quite a bit more optimistic so
to go back to the original thing our
play-doh and Freud's models of the soul
identical definitely not are they
similar they're similar in that they
have a try partition they're similar in
that there's there's a goal in mind of
living a better life there's similar in
that the bottom level looks very much
the same but they're not similar when it
comes to the stuff that's actually more
important they're not similar when it
comes to how in fact we ought to go
about unscrewing up our our lives our
existence
our mentalities our attitudes our
patterns of behavior so Plato and Freud
are really not doing the same thing even
though they do have tripartite views of
the soul that actually you know have
these these things in conflict with each
other to some extent hopefully this this
addresses the issue in a way it's you
know it's a sort of nuanced view yes
partly it you can connect them but
partly it's not that good of a fit